Daisy just got a lot more crazy mainly
because these buttheads decide to take
steroids that's right nothing says March
Madness like a bunch of riled up need
head zombies but hey don't let this
idiot pull you down there's plenty else
to bite into so let's dive into Daisy's
March Madness patch stuffing your face
has never been easier it all allows you
to down food and one go say goodbye to
table manners as you inhale the new
favorite tactical bacon and when canned
food gets bland how about some fresh
produce new spawns for peppers and
tomatoes add color to your diet but then
there's the rotten potato who could very
well be the spawn of Satan his rotten
power can stop you from passing him and
he also doesn't let you pass through
doorways wash that food down with some
rain because now you can bottle up God's
delicious tears in your canteen or water
bottle unfortunately rain will now make
you wet which can lead to hypothermia
and considering you can only snag one
percent of water each catch you better
be parched oh great so now yourself well
let's get those clothes off and into
some of the hottest fashion to hit the
town slip into a cozy wool coat and top
it off with a spiffy flat cap for a fit
that will impress all of the zombies and
for all you OCD designers out there you
can now paint green and black colors for
the ballistic helmet and your best
friend the firefighter axe hot cha and
why not show off that kungfu axe grip
with some advanced action moves all
two-handed melee weapons like the
baseball bat or shovel have brand new
animations in the form of low and aim
stances forced and crouch and prone
positions even the can opener gets a
facelift one second you're opening a
nice can of peaches the next you're
jabbing into some zombie flesh but you
better have a back-up ready how about
new products like the sickle or even
give this hoe a try this time it's on
the house new green and black color
variants are also available for the SKS
rifle and now for the first time at out
attachments for the m4 can now be
painted and of course brand new weapons
like these Porter 22 CR 75 pistol and
fibia s which is just another pistol and
the 1911 pistol is available for taking
map updates bring more police stations
and medical centers as well as a cute
lush little town northeast called janaya
polana which doesn't seem to house any
zombies at the moment so get it while
it's hot because they'll be moving in
next update speaking of which zombies my
god just when you thought the lack of
pathfinding and physics was annoying
enough they go ahead and hit the gym
they're faster they're nimbler they're
smarter and and there's plenty of them a
new zombie respawn mechanic makes things
interesting every time you kill one
there's another one around the corner so
it's easy to find yourself in a rut ah
but remember there's a magical loophole
to all of your troubles and it's called
the rotten potato baby oh yeah what now
[ __ ] look at that stupid get out of
here you idiot no one wants you go home
you idiot these new zombie mechanics are
pending and will most likely be toned
down next update so hang in there
survivor that's all for this patch
thanks for watching see you next time
you